you ready yes sir I'm ready
you will kill
the ekakalaka my name is Ricardo Villar
I'm originally from Brazil I immigrated
to us two years ago in Brazil people
know about me and my knives but in
America nobody knows me if I do well in
this competition people in America
probably gonna know my name too
forged by the [__] tribe in the Kingdom
of London during the early 1800s the
ekakalaka was a Fierce and imposing
weapon designed for executions the
double-edged blade featured a thick
spine and large Crescent tip giving it
the ability to forcibly chop with ease
this powerful weapon with an ornate
shape quickly became associated with
wealth dignity and social position among
men and women in the [__] tribe the
ecaccalaca can be seen in the 2018
Blockbuster film Black Panther
[Music]
the nagamaki
my name is Bryson Cox I'm 21 years old
I'll describe myself as very shy I like
to work alone when I'm away from my shop
for long periods of time it drives me
crazy reaching its peak use during the
Miro Machi era the nagamaki was a long
two-handed weapon that assisted Samurai
Warriors of feudal Japan for over four
centuries
it's slightly curved blade nearing 30
inches in length and equally long handle
gave the user complete and precise
control making it a highly effective and
lethal slicing weapon ideal for infantry
Warriors combating Horsemen
traditional Japanese swords have had a
long-standing influence on pop culture
Weaponry especially in fantasy films
like Lord of the Rings where the Elvish
Lang shares a similar Hilton blade
construction as the nagamaki
I'm gonna take care of the ikakalaka I'm
gonna start forging the lamp and forging
the body of the blade then I'm gonna
make that weird tip I'm using water on
the Anvil just to make the teeth a
little cooler this is a very old
technique to give me the control to make
the shoulders better
the tip is done time to get into the oil
that's hard I have a plate that's good
to turn in but I think I can do better
so let's turn on the forge and start
over
I love so much this job that I'm making
twice
what took me hours before it just took
me minutes this time
and now I'm done I love when a plane
comes together
I quench the second blade
the blade is straight it's hard and I'm
much more confident than the second
project so the second one is the one I'm
gonna compete with what I did different
in this blade is has a different edge
geometry and a harder taper
everything is coming together now it's
time to go and see how does it gonna
perform
for me it's okay I'm happy
I'm pretty nervous going to make my
first Japanese sword
I think the biggest challenge is going
to be the length of the nagamaki it's
longer than anything I've ever made
before and it's going to be hard to keep
all that straight
the first thing I do is taking it down
to size
straightening this blade is a hassle
it's wanting to curve like a banana and
I'm having to straighten it out little
by little
I had to be very meticulous on the
amount of curve it has I feel like I got
a pretty good sound blade but we won't
know anything until after the quench
the blade takes a warp oh man that's not
good it actually straightened the blade
out that made it to where I was under
parameters for the minimum Bend in the
blade I have to heat it back up put a
bin back in it and re-quench freaking
out a little bit
as I do my second quench I pull my blade
out and it has the bin requirements now
so it worked out oh it's just there
I'm just relieved
it's hard it's time to start thinking
about the hibaki
yeah
for the most part the hibaki is stuck
together it's uglier than sin but this
competition I think mainly it's about
function more than pretty the guard is
very important everything needs to be
smooth oh that's a tight fit feels
really good it's just a little bit heavy
the nagamaki being too heavy can make it
unwieldable and make it uncomfortable to
swing around because right where the
guard is it's a little heavy a mill a
simple pattern into the Super to losing
weight
that actually feels a lot better now
all I like is the wrapping and doing a
final cleanup I only have a few little
things to do on day four
this is cool
welcome to the Keel test
well your ikakalakas look interesting
and exotic but what kind of lethal
damage can they do well to find that out
I'm going to take your weapon deliver
some lethal blows on this ballistics
dummy Ricardo you're first you ready yes
sir I'm ready let's go for this
foreign
thank you it's got a good weight to it
the handle construction is comfortable
when you're swinging in this it digs
deep that is a sharp edge and when
you're penetrating it really digs
and cuts on the way out overall sir
it'll kill thank you sir
all right please miss to find out how
lethal your nagamakis are I will take
your weapons delivered killing blows
slashes and thrusts on this wild boar
carcass Braxton ready for this I'm ready
thank you
all right Braxton your nagamaki here is
definitely not boring
it is razor sharp every cut with this
thick wild boar carcass allowed me to
peel off layers of the very thick height
that it has also the lightness that you
have with this blade allows for
switching with the grip here it's got
very good grip in the handle I can index
exactly where the edges at all times
overall sir your naganaki
will kill thank you two blades One
champion you decide the winner forged in
fire war of weapons